réaction d' enthousiasme à l'inversé de
kingston en ontario il ya de quoi
le prix nobel de physique est décerné un
de leurs professeurs arthur mcdonald's
avec le japonais taka qui agita le prix
récompense leur découverte sur la nature
exacte des neutrinos
c'est le quatrième canadien à recevoir
ce prix prestigieux en physique michel
ça change pas la vie prix nobel mais
quand même
oh oui ça change la vie céline lis et
bing ce soit un prix donné un canadien
pour ce qu'on appelle de la grande
science et la science qui coûte cher de
la science qui prend d annie qui fait fi
des centaines de personnes d'ailleurs
écoutons le professeur mcdonald's lui
témoigner son enthousiasme michel vous
avez vous même rencontrer l'équipe du
professeur mcdonald's dans leur
laboratoire à sudbury au moment où ils
publiaient leurs travaux le stay à 14
ans oui c'est en 2001 j'ai eu la chance
de descendre dans la grande 2002 km de
profondeur mine de nickel et là ils ont
construit l'observatoire géant qui est
en fait une sphère dans lesquels on a
mis de l'eau lourde
alors quand les neutrinos rendant la
terre ils sont absorbés certains sont
absorbés et la émettent une lumière que
l'on capté l'on peut mesurer la présence
de ces nutrinautes alors pourquoi c'est
si important michel pour notre
compréhension de l'univers parce que
c'est bien de ce oui absolument bon peu
de gens savent ce que c'est en fait la
matière la la plus abondante les
particules les plus ou moins denses et
les fautes on sait ce que l'on voit la
lumière la deuxième ce sont les
neutrinos et ont aussi dit est-ce que
c'est inutile ont une masse non pas de
masse alors ce que l'équipe du prix
nobel d'aujourd'hui a réussi à
déterminer
c'est qu'entre le moment où ils ont été
fabriqués dans le soleil moment il nous
arrive ils changent de forme et pour
changer de forme mais d'avoir une masse
et la masse elle était finie mans peu
cheap
alors est ce que des applications
pratiques à cette découverte
bon alors il n'y a jamais une
application pratico pratique pour ce
genre d'étude l'a naturellement ces
laboratoires bas ont conçu des
instruments de poing qui se retrouve par
la suite dans l'industrie mais ce qui
était fondamental c'est de prouver que
le canada était capable de mener à bien
ce genre d'étude là qui mène à un prix
nobel
d'ailleurs on écoute là dessus le
professeur lewy comme en mode fort ce
que alors le professeur mcdonald's ou
poursuit sa recherche avec ce prix nobel
a lorsqu'il veut trouver c'est ce qu'on
appelle la masse sombre la masse
manquante de l'univers 1 au prix nobel
on sait pas si vivre assez vieux pour ça
mais c'est sa quête
merci beaucoup